I took all the pills that I had I took
them all hi my name is J Armstrong my
name is Matt Peterson justin Pompton my
name is Kelvin young the first time I'd
ever used any substance at all I drank
with a couple of friends of mine and I
tried marijuana at the same time the
heavy substance abuse really happened at
the age of 21 prescription opioid abuse
is a lot more complicated than the media
and politicians make it out to be too
often sports-related injuries managed
with opioid pain relievers have been the
beginning of a path to addiction it's
true that some people who get
prescription opioids from their doctors
do become addicted to them but the
majority of people who abuse opioid
painkillers typically get them from
their friends relatives so I'm 14 15 16
years old and the guys I'm hanging out
with they're all 21 to 30 years old at
one point they broke out some dilaudid
which is a pharmaceutical opiate that
you can break down and inject and it
took me to the same place mentally and
emotionally that alcohol did but I
didn't you know try to fight anybody I
didn't puke I didn't pee my pants I
didn't try to take my clothes off in
public or any of the other crazy stuff
that I was doing with alcohol and you
know at the time it was like a miracle
like oh my god like why didn't we find
this sooner the fact is that many of
these individuals already have
experience abusing drugs from alcohol to
marijuana to inhalants to drugs like
valium for me I started drinking when I
was about 13 14 years old
so by the time I reached age 26 27 I
graduated so to speak
to cocaine and heroin 13 I started
drinking and smoking pot then it's
probably bout two years later cocaine
was introduced the first time i abused
opiate painkillers I have my wisdom
teeth taken out and my friends they
taught me how to crush up a pill and
then snort it I started selling
prescription pills I was selling cocaine
crack heroin weed anything I could
pretty much get my hands on and then I
started using the drugs myself at least
half of all individuals whose overdose
deaths are attributed to an opioid also
have some other drug in their system at
death and it's these drugs in
combination that are especially deadly I
[Music]
didn't plan on living another second so
I didn't try to go to a place where I
could hide I took all the pills that I
had I took them all and I did all the
heroin that I got because I know mixing
benzos with opiates does the trick you
know and and it should have done the
trick
[Music]
people who use drugs of all kinds are
people who are trying to medicate some
sort of deep inner distress it doesn't
mean they're bad people it means they're
desperately looking for a way out and
can't figure out anything but drugs a
lot of the reasons why did initially
begin to use substances was a lot due to
low self esteem no sense of self-worth
and insecurities the theme of my
childhood is that I didn't feel wanted I
didn't feel like I belonged and I felt
afraid growing up as the youngest
thought of five I felt different I felt
less than what I did heroin I felt good
you know it didn't um the feeling of
feeling less than inadequate me growing
up as an only child the son of a pastor
I just wanted to fit in when I smoke pot
and drink for the first time I felt felt
accepted it's true that doctors have
over prescribed opioids in the past and
now they've been cutting back since
around 2011 and this is a good
development however what doctors do in
their office will have no effect on
people who never got the prescription
opioids from their doctors and it also
has unintended consequences for patients
who truly are in pain and need those
medications
you
[Music]